the movie is set in a dystopian America
where a deadly pandemic has spread
through some northern states the weird
thing about this pandemic is that anyone
who speaks will die a news report shows
graphic images of some people that fell
victim to the pandemic in another video
a terrified woman is seen recording
herself while inside a car her
daughter's mouth has been taped shot so
that she doesn't scream and the woman is
holding a sign which mentions don't make
noise too bad tweeting doesn't also get
people killed due to all of this the
government has declared a state of
emergency while suggesting everyone stay
indoors and switch off their phones just
a few days later the pandemic has
already decimated parts of the country
in an underground Metro there's blood
and dead bodies everywhere the surviving
passengers have taken Refuge inside
train carriages nervously hoping for the
catastrophe to end suddenly a baby
starts crying and his mother fails to
make him stop terrified of the noise a
group of passengers proceed to kick the
baby out of the train but the mother
decides to leave with him sadly her
decision turns out to be fatal as in
just a matter of seconds something
catches up to them following this the
movie rewinds back to the time where it
all started a group of archaeologists
are digging through Uncharted caves in
Pennsylvania one thousand feet beneath
the Appalachian Trail they come across a
massive never-before-seen dark chamber
and begin to celebrate however suddenly
they hear strange noises coming from
inside of it and lo and behold the
researchers come under attack by unknown
flying creatures who instantly kill them
and fly out of the mine the movie then
cuts to a high school in Montclair New
Jersey a deaf teenager named Ali Andrews
is waiting for a bus when she realizes
that a bunch of douchebags are mocking
her for being deaf she ignores them and
decides to walk back home Ali lost her
hearing ability in a car accident three
years ago she also lost her paternal
grandparents in the crash she
communicates with others through sign
language lip reading and speaking also
douchebag detection meanwhile a guy
named Rob shows up and offers to walk
her home they both have a major crush on
each other but always fall short of
admitting it at work Ali's father Hugh
gets a call from his wife Kelly who
informs him that their daughter was
again bullied at school this upsets him
but there's not much he can do about it
ever since Ali lost her hearing ability
Hugh and Kelly have become very
protective of their daughter and often
have fights about it Ali lives with her
parents brother Jude and terminally ill
maternal grandmother Lynn the Andrews
family also have a pet dog Otis at night
Rob sends Ali A fascinating video of a
colony of what looks to be bats flying
somewhere at 3am Kelly wakes Ally up and
asks her to come downstairs she notices
that her entire family is in the living
room glued to the TV looking worried all
windows are closed and the fireplace has
been covered by plastic the TV is
reporting that several U.S cities are
under attack by an unknown species of
pterosaur-like creature referred to as
vesps they are Unleashed onto Humanity
when some researchers blasted through
the ancient rockfall that was sealed off
for millions of years the creatures can
kill humans in a matter of seconds and
using noise to locate their prey because
of this the US government has declared a
state of emergency and asked people to
stay indoors and be quiet as everyone
watches the news in horror Ali suggests
that they head to the countryside as it
is both quieter and safer Hugh agrees
and everyone starts packing their
belongings one of his friends Glenn also
joins them and together they set out for
the countryside later Ali and her family
stop at a gas station to refuel their
cars she uses the opportunity to take
Otis out to pee while Hugh tries to keep
his son Jude entertained suddenly he
hears Ali screaming and quickly runs to
her a man has held her at gunpoint and
is demanding keys to Hugh's car he was
about to comply but Glenn shows up to
his rescue and shoots the robber in the
foot terrified the Andrews take the
man's gun and drive away leaving the
robber to be killed by the creatures
however before they can get far the
group comes across a massive traffic jam
that's blocking all the interstate
highways Glenn proposes an alternative
and they go off-road while driving
through the countryside Glen and
suddenly comes across a herd of fleeing
deer he quickly swerves his car in order
to avoid a crash but ends up tumbling
down the embankment the Andrews
immediately go to check on him and find
him alive sadly he is trapped inside the
car the family tries everything to save
Glenn including using a nut wrench to
open the door and calling 9-1-1 but
nothing works at last Glenn realizes
that he is eventually going to bleed out
so he asks Hugh to hand him his gun and
leave with his family distraught he
doesn't want to leave his best friend
alone but for the sake of his family he
agrees unfortunately just as the family
is about to leave Otis senses something
and starts barking repeatedly this
attracts the vests and they attack the
vehicle with tremendous intensity just
when all hope seems to be lost Glenn who
is still trapped inside the car starts
firing his gun to lure the creatures
towards him he manages to save the
Andrews temporarily but gets himself
killed in the process all this time Otis
keeps on barking hence left with no
choice Hugh makes the difficult decision
and lets the dog out of their car to Die
the Andrews then realize that they can't
drive away in their car without
attracting the vasps so they decide to
abandon it Hugh lights his car on fire
to distract the vasps and sets out on
foot with his family to find a shelter
they walk for hours and Lynn struggles
to keep up with her coughing putting the
family at risk by evening the family
comes across an isolated house
surrounded by a high fence and a locked
gate when they try getting in the gate
makes a noise and attracts the vasps
soon the homeowner also comes out with a
gun seemingly unaware of the current
situation she tries threatening The
Intruders but the vesps immediately
swarm her and rip her apart damn she
didn't deserve that after the incident
Hugh looks around the property for an
alternate exit and comes across a storm
drain tunnel that leads into the
compound he Ventures into the property
first to make sure it's safe after
getting the green light from Hugh Ali
and the others enter the tunnel but
inside Jude comes across a rattlesnake
which makes him scream and detract the
vasps the vasps kill the snake but they
also bite Kelly's Leg with time running
out Hugh quickly operates a wood chipper
to distract the creatures and shreds
them to death in the next scene the
family finally enters the house and
cleans Kelly's wounds before going to
bed Ally contacts Rob and finds out that
his parents have been killed by the
creatures worried she asks him to get
out of the city but before Rob can
respond the call disconnects meanwhile
amidst all the chaos and despair a
religious cult is on the rise that is
seeking new recruits and killing
non-believers the next day Lynn again
examines Kelly's wounds and learns that
it is infected realizing that the wound
is going to continue to spread without
antibiotics Hugh headset to find a
medical store with Ally after walking
silently for an hour they come across a
deserted City and look for a pharmacy
ultimately they find one but it is dark
deserted and stinking of rotten flesh as
Hugh collects the medicine Ali notices
vesp eggs growing inside human corpses
lying around the store she inadvertently
makes some noise and alerts the
creatures now the duo is stuck inside
the store with several vasps fortunately
he thinks of a plan he silently lights a
mop on fire and activates the fire alarm
the noise from the fire alarm and the
water sprinkler distract the creatures
and the father-daughter Duo manages to
escape unharmed outside they are
approached by a reverend who seems to
have cut his tongue it turns out he is
the leader of the cult that's going
around recruiting people and killing
non-believers the Reverend asks them to
join his flock but he refuses and walks
away they manage to safely return home
with antibiotics and Kelly begins to
recover the next day Ali approaches Hugh
and informs him that she watched the
news at night which stated that the
vesps can't stand intense cold weather
hence people above the Arctic Circle are
surviving she also tells him about
regions called the gray these are places
where electricity has gone out and
people are being cut off from the world
when the battery of their phone or
computers are dying it is almost as if
the Dark Ages have arrived again later
that day the Reverend and his cult
members show up at Hughes Hideout he
again asks you to join their cult but is
again turned down as Hugh proceeds to go
back inside the reverence stops him and
writes him a creepy note which reads the
girl is fertile he looks them up and
down and goes back inside the Reverend
and his cult members assume Hugh is
going to fetch his fertile daughter for
them but he returns with a damn rifle
instead however the lunatics are unfazed
as they know he won't shoot them which
would create a loud noise and jeopardize
his family despite this Hugh takes the
safety of the rifle off and the cult
members finally go away later that
evening Ally gets a message from Rob he
tells her that he is headed north of the
country to The Refuge it is a place
where all the people can be safe from
the creatures but before Ali gets to ask
him more about it she loses her phone
signal at midnight Hugh and Kelly wake
up to noises coming from outside he
grabs his rifle and checks the main door
while Kelly wakes Lin and Jude Up Hugh
doesn't see anyone at the door however
when Jude checks he notices a little
girl his age standing outside the the
girl looks afraid so Kelly decides to
let her in worried the Andrews family
provides her with a warm blanket and
asks her how she got here but the little
girl does not respond just then Kelly
notices some scars on the girl's jaw and
Hugh inspects her mouth they discover to
their horror that the girl doesn't have
a tongue She is a member of the
reverence cult and most likely sent by
him the Andrews family have been set up
they check her waist and realize that
she's been strapped with multiple mobile
phones meanwhile Ali wakes up in her
room and notices a phone taped to a
cross on her window the phone alarm
suddenly starts to go off and attracts
the creatures freaking Ali out the phone
strapped to the little girl also start
to go off and the family scrambles to
take them off hugh dumps the phones in
the water while Ali runs into the living
room as everything is happening the
creatures start breaking their Windows
Hugh and Jude try to keep the vesps out
while Ali and others go into the
basement to hide unfortunately masked
cult members had been waiting for Ally
and they grab her from the basement
Kelly attacks the men but they kick her
into the the wall knocking her down the
men carry Ally out and the little girl
also goes with them enraged Lynn leaves
the safety of the house and follows the
men outside she grabs two of The Three
Men and signals Ali to flee the girl
obliges and as soon as she reaches a bit
far Lynn who is still holding the cult
members starts screaming at the top of
her lungs this eventually attracts the
vests and they rip the three humans to
shreds the rest of the family also comes
outside but all they can do is watch in
horror just then the Reverend shows up
and abducts Ally before leaving he even
taunts Hugh to stay silent however
taking advantage of the rain Hugh Kelly
and Jude quietly follow them and launch
a surprise attack an enraged Hue
strangles the cult leader with a rifle
but the Reverend stabs him with a knife
in the waist however Hugh summons all
his strength and again gets back up he
uses his late best friend Glenn's
classic headbutt and Knocks The Cult
leader down as Kelly takes the other
cult members out she then helps her
husband by taking the knife out of his
waist the Reverend attempts to get up
but he you again gets on his case this
time he hammers the cult leader to death
with the rifle after the encounter the
Andrews family returns home while the
tongueless girl walks away with her
mother following this the movie Fast
forwards by a few weeks where the family
is seen trekking across the country they
initially arrive at the safe haven that
is the Refuge in the final scene Ali and
Rob are hunting vests in the forest the
movie ends as Ali wonders whether the
vasps will adapt to the cold and if the
humans will adapt to the life of Silence
like she did when she lost her hearing
in other words very little progress has
been made since the beginning of the
movie subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching